TUCKER CARLSON IS UP NEXT
* * * * * * * * * * * * * * * *
* * * * * * * * * * * * * * * ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT.
THERE IS A LOUD DEBATE IN
WASHINGTON TO PARTICIPATE IN
BORDER'S ACUTE OR.
TO BUILD A WALL AND HOW MUCH ICE
SHOULD GET WITH DETENTION CENTER
BIG ENOUGH TO HOLD EVERYONE THEY
NEED TO HOLD.
PEOPLE ARGUE ABOUT THESE
QUESTIONS EVERYDAY.
YOU WATCH IT ON TV SO IT SEEMS
LIKE THE PARTIES ARE DIVIDED ON
THE MATTER.
BUT ON A DEEPER LEVEL -- LEVEL,
THERE IS NO DEBATE BUT A
CONSENSUS.
EVERYONE IN THE POLITICAL SYSTEM
KNOWS IN OUR FAITH THAT MASS
IMMIGRATION IS GOOD FOR THE
ECONOMY.
IMMIGRANTS MAKE US RICHER AND
THE CHAMBER OF COMMERCE TELLS US
THAT.
THINK TANKS TO START TO PROVE
IT'S TRUE.
AND THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY, IT IS
A BEDROCK PRINCIPLE.
AMERICA WOULD COLLAPSE WITHOUT
HIS STEADY TORRENT OF NEW BIBLES
DEVELOPING.
THAT IS WHAT THEY TELL US.
IMMIGRATION DOES NOT JUST
IMPROVE THE ECONOMY.
WE WOULDN'T HAVE AN ECONOMY
WITHOUT IT.
>> I WANT US TO BE A COUNTRY
WHERE HARDWORKING IMMIGRANTS WHO
PAY TAXES, AND BY THE WAY, ONE
HAVE UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS PAY
FEDERAL INCOME TAXES.
>> THESE PEOPLE ARE JUST
WAITING, WAITING FOR A CHANCE TO
BE ABLE TO CONTRIBUTE FULLY.
AND BY THAT STANDARD, 11 MILLION
UNDOCUMENTED ALIENS ARE ALREADY
AMERICANS IN MY VIEW.
>> WE CANNOT CONTINUE WITH THIS
ECONOMY.
>> OUR HISTORY AND THE FACTS
SHOW THAT IMMIGRANTS ARE A NET
PLUS FOR THE ECONOMY AND OUR
SOCIETY.
>> Tucker: HALF OF THE
ILLEGALS PAY THEIR TAXES.
YOU SHOULD BE IMPRESSED AND
GRATEFUL.
AND A NEW TALKING POINT AS YOU
CAN TELL FROM THE AGING VIDEO WE
SHOWED YOU BUT LIKE EVERYTHING
IN THIS COUNTRY, IT IS
ACCELERATED DRAMATICALLY THE
PAST COUPLE OF YEARS.
THE LEFT'S NEW POSITION IS
IMMIGRANTS ARE NOT JUST GOOD FOR
AMERICA, BUT BETTER FOR AMERICA
THAN YOU ARE.
THEY DON'T COMPLAIN, THEY DON'T
FILE HR COMPLAINTS, THEY DON'T
GET EXPENSIVE LONG-TERM DISEASES
LIKE DIABETES OR OPIOID
ADDICTION BUT DO WHAT THEY ARE
TOLD.
THE LEADERS ARE WHAT THEY'VE
ALWAYS WANTED.
KRISTEN GILLIBRAND IS RUNNING
FOR THE PRESIDENT EXPLAINED THAT
EVERY SINGLE IMMIGRANT IN
AMERICA IS GOOD, NO MATTER HOW
THEY GOT HERE OR WHY.
JUST BY VIRTUE OF THE FACT THEY
ARE IMMIGRANTS.
AND HAVE I HEARD ANYBODY SAY
THAT ABOUT AMERICAN CITIZENS?
NO, DON'T HOLD YOUR BREATH.
BUT GILLIBRAND MENTIONED
IMMIGRANTS, WATCH.
>> THERE IS NO SUCH THING AS AN
ILLEGAL HUMAN.
[APPLAUSE]
>> IMMIGRANT POPULATIONS ACROSS
THE STATE, REFUGEE POPULATIONS
THAT MAKE ECONOMY STRONGER AND
MAKE THE CITY AND STATE
STRONGER, THAT MAKE THE COUNTRY
STRONGER.
>> Tucker: PULSES PERSON IN
WASHINGTON.
BUT SHE IS SAYING SOMETHING
EVERYBODY BELIEVES, IT MAKES OUR
ECONOMY STRONGER.
AND IT IS IT TRUE?
A GREAT JOB IN THIS COUNTRY,
HIGHLY PATRIOTIC AND SUCCESSFUL
IN BUSINESS, GREAT NEIGHBORS AND
FRIENDS.
EVERYBODY KNOWS PEOPLE LIKE THAT
AND EVERYBODY IS GLAD THEY ARE
HERE.
BUT NOT EVERY IMMIGRANT IS LIKE
EVERY OTHER IMMIGRANT.
DON'T TELL KIRSTEN GILLIBRAND
BUT THEY ARE NOT ALL THE SAME.
THE CURRENT IMMIGRATION SYSTEM
TREATS THEM LIKE THEY ARE.
TREATS PEOPLE LIKE WIDGETS.
THE GOVERNMENT DOES VIRTUALLY
NOTHING TO CELEBRATE THE GOOD
FROM THE BAD.
A SYSTEM LIKE THAT NOT DESIGNED
TO HELP AMERICA BUT DESIGNED FOR
THE BENEFIT OF FOREIGNERS.
BY THAT MEASURE, IT HAS BEEN
WILDLY SUCCESSFUL.
A NEW STUDY SHOWS LAST YEAR
IMMIGRANTS LIVING IN THE
UNITED STATES SPEND $120 BILLION
TO THE COUNTRIES THEY CAME FROM.
EVEN IN THE AGE OF EXPANDING
COST FROM A $120 BILLION IS A
LOT OF MONEY.
MORE FOR EXAMPLE THEN WE SPENT
ON THE FIRST GULF WAR.
MORE THAN TEN ENTIRE RUSSIAN
MILITARY SPENDS EVERY TWO YEARS.
ENOUGH MONEY TO BUY AT COSTCO,
NOT THE STUFF ON THE SHELF BUT
THE ENTIRE COMPANY AND STILL
HAVE $15 BILLION LEFT OVER.
IT IS A LOT OF MONEY AND ALL OF
IT COULD BE GOING TO AMERICANS
WHO BADLY NEED IT.
BUT INSTEAD, MEXICO RECEIVED
$33 BILLION IN REMITTANCE LAST
YEAR.
THE COUNTRIES ON PRESIDENT SAID
THE ECONOMY WOULD GO UNDER
WITHOUT THIS.
IN GUATEMALA, THE BUSINESS IN
THE UNITED STATES AMOUNTED TO A
FULL 11% OF ENTIRE GDP.
YOU KNOW SALVADOR AND HONDURAS,
18 AND 20% RESPECTIVELY.
IN THE PAST DECADES, THOSE THREE
COUNTRIES RECEIVED A TOTAL OF
$120 BILLION IN AN ARM MAN TENTS
FOR THE UNITED STATES.
BY THE WAY NOT JUST
LATIN AMERICA BENEFITING FROM
THIS.
CHINA WHO HARDLY NEEDS IT GETS
$15 BILLION IN REMITTANCES.
INDIA $10.5 BILLION VIETNAM,
NIGERIA $5.5 BILLION, RUSSIA
$3.5 BILLION AND WE CAN GO ON
AND ON.
NONE OF THIS IS A TECH ON
IMMIGRANTS BUT HELPING FAMILIES
BACK HOME AND GO FOR THEM IT'S
NOT THEIR FAULT.
IT IS OUR FAULT.
MUCH OF THIS MONEY HAS NEVER
BEEN TAXED AT ANY LEVEL.
MORE THAN 10 MILLION ILLEGAL
ALIENS WORKING IN THIS COUNTRY
UNDER THE TABLE.
THAT IS PART OF THE REASON
BETWEEN 2012 AND 2016 AN
ESTIMATED 39 MILLION
SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBERS WERE
STOLEN FROM AMERICANS FOR
FRAUDULENT USE.
IN EFFECT THAT IS RARELY
REPORTED.
BUT LEGAL OR NOT COME IMMIGRANTS
SEND EARNINGS ABROAD AND PAY
NOTHING WHEN THEY DO IT BECAUSE
REMITTANCES ARE UNTAXED.
IT IS A PRETTY GOOD DEAL FOR
MEXICO AND GUATEMALA.
WHEN IS THE LAST TIME YOU MADE
FINANCIAL TRANSACTION THAT
WASN'T TAXED?
CAN YOU REMEMBER?
AT ONE POINT THE ADMINISTRATION
PROPOSED REMITTANCE TECH BUT
THEY DIDN'T LIKE THE IDEA.
SO IT WENT NOWHERE.
WE CAN'T FIX THAT ON THE SHOW
BUT WHAT WE CAN DO IS BE HONEST
ABOUT WHAT IS HAPPENING.
IMMIGRATION IS GOOD FOR THE
ECONOMY, SURE, IT CAN BE GOOD.
IMMIGRATION IS ALWAYS GOOD FOR
THE ECONOMY?
MORE IMMIGRATION IS ALWAYS
BETTER FOR THE ECONOMY?
NO.
THAT IS A LIE.
THERE IS NOTHING TO SUPPORT THAT
CLAIM.
THERE IS A LOT OF EVIDENCE TO
DISPROVE IT.